ciao per fortuna non soffro di questa
fobia lanati da e fobia che
el'irrazionale incontrollabile paura che
un oca in qualche punto imprecisato ci
stia guardando non mi guardarono paura
anomale again
si torna così i maiali dai tori di come
un maiale comunque non tutti hanno
sentito dalla risata sono i pochissimi
perché si vede come fatto ridere molto
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è paure e fobie
tramontate di oggi ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia una carissima amica di cui però
anche molta paura che è martina pinto se
contente stesso limitata per questo
tempo in particolare il 96 contenuto
invitato il compleanno e d'ora in poi
dovrei avere paura di me non ho fatto il
compleanno quindi non può essere stato
invitato al mio contratto negli anni
passati non m'è mai invitato cambia la
mia laurea mia compleanni sempre di
notte giuro faccio una festa non
ricordarmi almeno dal matrimonio
grazie ciao gu ho letto del loro
messaggio di vita buttata là delle fobie
io per esempio di un paio come
l'aracnofobia la fobia vertigini aco
fobia le classiche storie forse che
tutti la cosa qua del lago fortebraccio
talmente nell'attesa quando di tutto di
miseno lago si spezzò e andò al settore
suino adesso tutto veramente era
visibile sa mai e si fanno il medico non
mi riusciva a prendere l'aveva dato
questa dieci volte ed ha detto la faccia
male
la risata mai avuto il livido no a
tirana il sangue no ora finirà con quel
fatto che tu mi abbia invitato come un
tema del genere mi fa proprio pensare
che tu ti sia scordato di me per altri
temi molto più in linea con me ma tipo
franzon resto del primo allora bisogna
parlare di questa cosa si dimentica di
me io li invita quando sei buche
stiamo arrivando fino a questo punto
allora bisogna raccontare questa back
story
io mi innamorai di martina quando
lavoravamo insieme a nun è vero sì ma
ero io che ero innamorata di te è andata
così e mi innamorai di te allora
raccontiamola tutta aperto il vaso di
pandora e adesso ti faccio il minore di
martina tanto che chiesi una pausa al
mio ragazzo ed era così ma che mi ha
fatto molto ridere adesso sparisci io ho
lasciato il mio ragazzo
ci abbiamo tutti denunciati i nostri
ragazzi però il problema col è stato nel
momento in cui magari tutti si è resa
conto che magari avevano interesse che
io subito ho avuto l'interesse poi è
successo che ho pensato non mi si caga e
appena successa una cosa ha detto che
presidente sotto sotto martina ci è
mancato qualcosa
esatto in quel momento c'è stato il
cambio non l'abbiamo pensato non mi
vuole quindi è gay e lavora realmente
sul fatto che se ti interessa un ragazzo
capisce tanto magari anche la stessa
cosa però fidate mia sorella di yoga la
coppia per la mia lingua affari gli
specchi negli anni ho sempre le carico
sulla faccia sulle braccia e cose così
nota lecco anche adesso e quindi mi
avvicino lei urla e si agita perché non
vale viola leggi capiente
grazie a questa fulminata sulla via del
sole le vive nella presa che io ho paura
il commodore e nei tocchi uno schifo e
poi ho paura anche del cocomero che
secondo me corsa però molto succosa
accomodare ma al riparto passato puzza
nome cocomero amica non puzza dice anche
il profumo a com'ero io alla silhouette
fobie è un po la fobia dei piedi ci sa
mi fanno un po schifo noti pro
preferireste avere delle mani cioè
proprio tagliata qua alle caviglie
mogherini e come bravi ma va bene negli
anni ho imparato ad accettarli però mi
fanno schifo
cioè tipo quelli che ci sono i piedi ma
che cos'è che conosciuto capito già nel
mentre nella foga succede che poi non ho
mai capito ma come fai nella foga ciao
io alla fobia delle persone che mangiano
bocca testa che fanno rumore masticando
a favore degli uccelli e una volta per
radicarlo dentro casa brani di the
meaning lo so ma vedo cosa che rimane
aiutare il suo l'armadio ad una velocità
che tifa gente la vanoni non poté
chiamai mia madre ea liberare alla fine
voglio compagno di mia madre io stavo
organizzando tremavo la capisco io pure
ho il terrore degli uccelli di un altro
sì quando ti vengono vicino mi fanno
paura
volano le cose che volano le cose che
uno si ritrovano i treni no ma le api si
a me la erre moscia mi piace un sacco
lavoro renzo accadere
comincia a parlare così 9 mar a eremo
essere quella giusta
quando c'è la naturale per da un sacco
sexy grazie
anzi ciao conquistò mandando questo
passaggio dal cesso di casa mia perché
sto affrontando la mia più strana e
profondo ha paura di cariche è quella di
tirare lo sciacquone dopo aver pagato
una tappa ma lui quella che lui creato
ma come si fa ad aver paura dello
sciacquone io di fatto ho paura quando
faccio la cacca che lo sarebbe anche
bacinella da botta grande paura è quella
che in mente io sto facendo qualcosa di
importante che richiede concentrazione
un lavoro insomma che possa sentire la
risata di tuo fratello e che quindi di
colpo io perda tutta la concentrazione è
cominci a cadere a terra ed è stato
naturale è in realtà il discorso di
enrico e che enrico è sempre sempre
trovato di felicità esatto cioè tu sei
allegro e la faccia doveva essere al
libro perché ha un fratello come te no
no no è possibile capito certo il mio
amico ha la fobia dei peli degli animali
quando gli ho comunicato che stavo per
prendere un cane ha guardato il vuoto
per dieci minuti si è alzato non caso in
bagno è una più tornato però un po lo
capisco come fai una vela fobia dei peni
vive primi aspetta quasi tutti pieni e
dei peli degli angeli tra bra me le
fanno schifo per i degli animali
io so al cane se trovi peli in giro mi
fa schifo una fobia con tutte le cose
che ci sono al mondo di cui aver paura
il ciao allora una volta sono nella mia
camera è improvvisamente sentito la voce
pensi che si guida solo giro la testa e
vedo un ragno enorme sono spaventato un
casino perché ho paura da far schifo
degli animali che non usano il
congiuntivo a renzi che se qui da sola
parola minacciosi sci
ecco questa è la vera natura ne fa
schifo siamo una birra è una bionda
questi stessi capite in questo momento
scusami
riproviamoci in olanda bene bene alla ln
ha detto del e sostituisce alla r
volevi dire da piatti secondo me preme
che li na la tra land è lecita ma lei
dice del e sostituisci alla r la m ci
stanno prendendo in giro forse ho detto
bene bene bene bene bene bene
scusa ma ma fa il medico che studia a
scuola mia astana mia parte del corpo il
bene bene è un il bene sono le azioni
della gente non è una parte del corpo
scema sì forse ha mica detto bene quello
che volevi dire bene che torre né forse
non l'editto belle quello che volevi
dire la mia grande creativi ma non di
quella giusta ma di quella dei danari
cruciani motivo è così da quando mi è
pesato non poco della valle se tu fai
qua se mi metti tipo instagram così ci
sono ammette il modello mi sono
diventata mascella perché sono giorni in
cui interno mi sta affrontando senza
pace
tanto che sta facendo facendo senza
facendo buzzurro farlo mangiare senza
farmi bere in testa farlo senza non ci
ha pensato io ti ho detto guglielmo
prendiamo del cibo
mandiamo enrico comprare del cibo il tuo
fratello stava morendo di fame di
bombardarlo stampa sempre una cavalla
così scontato tutto prima nel doppiaggio
mi fossi una bolina si anch'io vorrei
mangiare ma chi ti ha chiesto un parere
era quella gola cosa è finita la nutella
altra parte c da c nella bella ma non
posso farti un dm vocale perché mi
vergogno troppo e credo di essere
l'unica con questa fobia vuole
leggerselo è una ragazza che scrive
quindi ma secondo me la devo fare un pò
così non va
io io ho paura delle mucche che mi
guardano mi mettono angoscia e
soggezione
mi sento giudicata da più bisogno di
sapere se questa fobia un nome e se
esiste qualcun altro che ne soffre
veramente si ridevamo perché quando
leggere una mucca oggi che stava tipo
cantando la paura di una mia amica e dei
cadaveri si è iscritta all'università
con me di medicina ha intonato il primo
anno quando comunque andavamo a vedere
le autopsie eccetera eccetera con un
altro compagno abbiamo legato la mano
del morto con lo spago e con dovizia
light eravamo la mano così la toccava
non ti dico la scenata che ha fatto
credo che ci ha paura questa scusa a
parte chi si fa ma io vi si accalora
faccia io ho paura da morire di non
morire
faccio questo appello così nell'etere e
mai dovessi morire assicuratevi che io
sia morta e tipo un'inizione d'aria non
lo so ma dove eravate la celebrazione
ricordiamo tutti quanti parti lo stai
facendo un programma interattivo
l'albero azzurro oggi bello magari pizzo
che ci siamo mangiati che si sta così a
io ho il terrore delle lucertole ma non
ho paura come 10 a tutti la fuga che se
vedo km di distanza una lucertola mizan
urlare appunta skitour lo penso che le
lucertole e lo capiscano che vogliano a
salire mentre dormono o comunque stiamo
cavando acquisto ha ripreso la lucertola
mi fa schifo proprio in modo che c'hanno
è che l'italia a quota e fa così ma va
bene e che non cercare di prendere la
piccola ma che sera d'estate vengono in
mente sono sempre piccolini genera costi
era molto grande e infatti riesce a
vedere di ripresa dc cioè era abbastanza
grosso tra mito e nella ricerca di
condirli nuovo partito
diadora un giovane nero dice che una
volta invece ne avevo preso un nuovo
video che si rivelato tutto così dopo un
po che era del re quando lo vedevo che
si era tranquillizzato il vostro vengono
interamente per farlo tornare nel mondo
del rimasto malissimo
questa è una di quelle cose che ti fa
tristezza 9 la rideva e morto
ho capito il significato della morte
[Risate]
ciao io ho la fobia nella parte finale
delle banane faccia qualcun gilioni non
ero alla fine se mi presentano una
banana richiesto capire l'origine sesso
tra sostegno disco mangiarla c'è
qualcuno che mangia quel pezzetto di
quello che ti presentano i bambini due
bar
io di una banana tali da il pezzetto
iniziale il pezzetto finale capisco
perfettamente per roma alice inibiti e
non c'entrano niente queste cose come ho
fatto anch'io ed i piedi anche io ed ha
neanche io c'è paura paura davvero
oppure dei morti eppure io questa
ragione questa che tu non c'era il la
mia fuga in cava mezzo il troppo alla
fobia del re leone e in particolare
della canzone dell'inizio video se
dovessi usare questo audio soprattutto
di mufasa per non si sa bene quale
ragione da quando ero piccola continua
tuttora quindi non posso vedere immagini
di invasa o sentire la canzone e non
capisco assolutamente il motivo a parte
che il cartone più bello che sia mai
stato fatto e il tuo preferito della
disney ha aperto e che secondo me il
migliore ed ho preferito più bello della
bella bestia non mi piaceva parlerà
parte di dispiace per me se la battono
il re leone e la carica di santoro
magari qualcuno sa bene chi è un pacco
beh in questo anche il taglio di per pit
mi sembri un po martin ha detto uno
famoso delle 2 pp segreto con il taglio
possa farti una pettinatura da ti faccio
una ragazza mentre parli ma anche con
molta brava così tanta pazzo un tutorial
storia allora ragazzi sono arrivati alla
fine di questo video io ringrazio
martina come subito mi ricordo che se
questo video ha fatto venire in mente
dei temi che potremo fare in futuro per
vita buttata dobbiamo sapere qua sotto
magari mettete dei like in modo a farmi
capire quali sono quelli che
preferireste rispetto agli altri finisca
questa treccia è pronta per il
matrimonio
comunque grazie a vero marty per esserci
stato scusami
io non lo trovo un gesto molto carino
questo qua disfare la grecia che ti ha
appena fatto
posso dirti calcio contro un gesto molto
carico la tua parti una treccia con
amore no st presentata qui
ecco io vorrei troppe capelli biondi
capelli lunghi siamo sorelle
noi siamo le sorelle pinte le sere team
se facesse una cosa un po più la regola
se no di doversi fare il tutto qua alto
così se un po maschilista java jre dice
raggiante invece tipo settimane roba qua
un po chiara ferragni capito sia con 8
meglio leone leone 3d come sei subito
chiara ma credo che ci siano delle
differenze
vorrei essere wilde
ma io lo perdono adesso sei maria
goretti
[Applauso]
ma mario moretti con le spezie alla
ricchissima la mia patate mais in mano
il gioco ma sarebbero state bene se
fossero state fine grazie per avermi
ricordato che il tuo regalo è stato
ucciso
ciao